tell you what let's just kick this off
we'll do a wrap
made up on the spot on your suggestions
once we've got five you know the number
it's the standard one we'll drop a beat
we'll get we'll get busy with it thomas
is spotlighted keith and who's this
lovely person with you keith
hi this is my girlfriend lindsay hi hi
hi lindsay lovely to have you both here
keith did you recently lead the tour de
france
i i no this is actually uh from running
not from cycling
okie dokie it's good you've got to stay
well lit and illuminated lest you be
bonked by a car and a perish so keith
and lindsey what would you like a rap
about
rejected ikea furniture names rejected
ikea furniture names that is absolutely
fantastic and really why i hate doing
gigs where people know that i can rap
thank you very much keith and lindsay a
pleasure to have you
here uh thomas you can get rid of them
kick them out i don't like that
suggestion
i'm joking guys um and let's get our
second suggestion who is it going to
be hey sahani welcome how are you
i'm very well how are you i'm fine super
where are you coming to us from
i'm coming to you from india whereabouts
in india
uh i am living in noida which is near
delhi
which is the cafeteria yeah when when i
i've only visited india
once i was in mumbai to do some shows in
2013
and i i didn't particularly like mumbai
and i bumped into a journalist
and she said oh you have to come to
delhi it's much better and at the time
this was when it was a lot of people
getting murdered and raped on buses in
delhi and i said
but aren't a lot of people getting
murdered and raped on buses in delhi and
she said it's still a much better city
than mumbai
so it's good to know that's uh that's
how great delhi is
um so so hani what would you like a rap
about
uh how about coding in javascript coding
in javascript absolutely fantastic do
you do you code yourself
yep i am i'm an engineer in the
pre-final year of engineering
okay great well congratulations for
being much cleverer than i think anyone
else here
uh and also everyone when i'm rapping
about coding in javascript keep an eye
on sahani because she'll just be there
going
what's he on about this is all a lie the
thing is i when i rap it's essentially
bullshitting people go
how do you know so much how good are you
convincing people that you know facts
amazing thank you so much sahani let's
get our third suggestion david cassie
what would you like a rap about
so you you already have a really tough
crowd tonight yes yes
they all look very miserable i i i feel
like i should make it easier for you i
would like to rap about
the history of photography the history
of photography
i'm not going to do any more of these
shows these are all far too difficult
amazing thank you
let's get our fourth suggestion thank
you so much cassie thank you david
so far rejected ikea furniture names
coding in javascript and the history of
photography who's number four
hey adama your hoodie you're not
reviewing this show are you
uh i might be oh dear that's not good
okay well i'm gonna nail this adam
where are you coming to us from uh from
manhattan germany
oh lovely stuff love it um that means i
may put a german accent
on for this segment what would you like
a rap about odama
uh about the development from the
functional to the bourgeois nuclear
family
oh [ __ ] hell development
from the bourgeois i don't even think i
know
any of these words to the nuclear family
brilliant thank you very much adam that
was fantastic
thank you for showing us your sewing
machine oh showing us your sewing
machine
showing as you sew in machine it's a
tongue twister i'm warming up um and
let's
get uh craigs here craig and who's that
with you craig
uh what would you like a rap about
uh what about the works of hitler
between 1907
and 1912. the works of hitler between
1907 and 1912
so presumably mean his artistic output
yeah hey paint ginger yeah yeah yeah
perfect brilliant
thank you so much craig for that really
it's really the cherry on the cake when
you get hitler isn't it that's
all internet arguments devolve into
hitler i shouldn't be doing this motion
while i mention his name
all internet arguments devolve into
hitler and all raps end with hitler
okay great thank you so much everyone to
remind you
the suggestions are rejected ikea
furniture names
coding in javascript the history of
photography the development from the
bourgeois to the nuclear family maybe in
a german accent
and the works of hitler between 1907 and
1912 definitely in a german accent
and i always say look don't worry
because it's not going to be anywhere
near as bad as you're expecting a
proudly educating middle-class white
british boy to be
but uh i'm fully expecting this to crash
and burn what an
ignomious beginning for our first one
let's uh let's do this let's drop this
beat
good sir and uh have some fun this is an
absolute smashing beat you may have
heard me use it before but i like it so
much
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
i'm a swedish man and i do it myself
went to ikea and i purchased a shelf the
name on the side of the box said belf
and i was like um sounds like ill health
i sent it back i wrote a strongly worded
letter
and said i key your furniture names can
get better improving that they're like
ours that's useful what about our table
it's called
schnuffle yeah really easy cause
anything rhymes do the swedish accent
and keep to that time
i know some people might get quite
pissed if i move on quick to the
javascript
it got deprecated it was such a hassle
people like nah no flash with apple but
java i know still persist to the day
new grounds everybody love to play on
those games
oh what we have we hold i'm gonna get on
my terminals start to cold
here's a little thing i'm offering to ye
getting energetic like the java coffee
get my arabica or a buster that's a
little coffee pun yeah we discover
i know in india you're looking like he's
really kind of blustering through this
one that's okay
throw your fists in the air and praise
that man called lumiere i don't mean
little candelabra from beauty and the
beast
i mean the guy developing the visual
feast for the eyes
try and get the plates negative positive
when you see
me let me talk about this when the
shutter clicks
you know the first photo what's a dick
pic mean clearly they said it was a
street scene
but you know we put it down between his
breaches had a look over there then you
gotta develop it
if it's in the dark room never let the
light slip in through the little chinks
there in the windows coming up to the
present yeah
it be move ever so fast and the light
glows
got the digital cameras yo and now apple
iphone's got the 12 megapixel on the
lens
three right there that's more than my
friends that i have
yeah you'd be getting wealthy if you
invested in kodak take a selfie
feeling kinda paranoid when i take a
polaroid if i wanna be with my family
cause i never avoid all the discussion
i'm used to you we gather around the
table so nuclear
people come thanksgiving from near and
far but how did we
get here moving from bourgeois i didn't
even realize that it's entered in the
description of family developing
oh wait i forgot the accent here we go
yes
i'll try and track it moving on the
graph now here we are we're reaching
nuclear
but not bourgeois bourgeois like
aristocracy
in the russian times pre-revolution yes
i'm feeling fine and who's the guy who
fought in both wars while technically
the first one
on all fours he was painting like
jackson pollock with the canvas
when he grows a mustache everybody's
hand goes up to the high
they say but when he was younger he
really liked to while away the time
there with the brush and some paint
and the beats ended there so we can't
wrap more what a shame
there we go some would say i
deliberately made it so i wouldn't have
to rap that much about hitler's artworks
and uh
you'd be correct you'd be absolutely
correct there feel slightly awkward that
i
uh even mentioned him i hope you enjoyed
that that was the wrap that we started
off with
um it can only get better from here is
what i'm gonna say it can only get
better
from here